one of the great distinction about
post-modernism is that is gone
you know first mother this was the 15
minutes of celebrity for those that
would have never had it otherwise you
know they when your sake of modernism is
incredibly alive and is rooted you know
in the hundreds of years innocence I
think modernist started in the rendering
the Renaissance somehow but really the
modernism even more really started I
will say with the Enlightenment you know
the Enlightenment two years 70 70 70 250
1750 you know around that time along
with a Diderot Dalembert innocence with
industrialization you know basically the
first first sounds of industrialization
and modernism is alive and well and a
great well as postmodern is gone it has
only one very good thing with it is that
a somehow erased or interesting history
you know and that is and that is very
important you know history tearing
criticism are the most important aspects
in in the development of design but
modernism is alive and well as I said
and blood of the young people are now
working you know allow the modernist way
and there's no more post-modernism
around it's really gone gone gone gone
to God and then but of course it's not a
style one is a style is a dead thing
modernism is an attitude it's not a
style modernist is a discipline another
style
modernism is intelligent another style
and so when you work that me along those
lines
your modernist designer you know
and that is what is great about so if I
will last forever by the way